and finally new rules to all the people
who've been telling me Bill you have to
do something on nepo babies
shut up I don't have to
but okay here it is
and if you haven't heard the term yet
here's a brief Montage of all the nepo
babies in the acting profession
beginning with Douglas Fairbanks Jr
that's right their moms and dads were
all stars too it doesn't make them bad
people or untalented in fact some nepo
babies did very well in their first big
roles
but let's also admit that they weren't
the only ones who could have done it but
when it's between a few good people and
one of them is going to get you this
kind of publicity who do you think is
going to get the part
so enjoy the good life nippos just don't
say you didn't have a huge advantage
or it didn't matter that much who your
parents were or it just got my foot in
the door this is Show Business
getting your foot in the doors 80 of it
yes yes
there are difficult roles that require
acting only the great ones can do but
most acting please Vin Diesel can do it
foreign
bodybuilders can do it
children can do it Steven Seagal could
do it
I did it
reality TV is acting acting like you
didn't know that glass of wine was going
to get thrown in your face
[Applause]
this is one reason why of the top rated
telecasts on television
Sports last year accounted for 94 of the
top 100 because it is the last Refuge of
meritocracy in America
show business is full of nepo babies
politics is full of nepo babies even
modeling which used to require the
Integrity to find a freakishly Perfect
14 year old in a small Slovenian Village
[Applause]
has fallen to nepotism but in sports
there are no nepo babies there are the
sons and daughters of former players but
it's not why they play Laila Ali didn't
knock out 21 opponents by smacking them
with her birth certificate
foreign
is the last place where it doesn't
matter who you are or where you're from
just what you do no one gets hired
either because it would make the team
look like America
or because they're rich white daddy
pulled strings
I don't trust the government media
churches judges juries Banks Jiffy Lube
or anyone on a dating app
anyone on a dating app covering their
chin with their hand
but I do trust that the 450 players in
the NBA are the absolute best 450
players the teams could find anywhere in
the world
the fact that this kid's future in the
NBA is not assured in fact it's the
opposite of assured
that's very assuring to me
everyone wants to see LeBron James son
play on the same team with his father
there hasn't been a feel-good story that
feel good since Macaulay Culkin escaped
from Neverland
all right
but just because we want to see it is
not going to make it happen only bronnie
James himself can do that Doc Rivers kid
plays but not because his father played
and so it's a great story in sports they
don't tell each other stories they
perform maybe that's why Sports looks to
me at least on TV like a place that has
really good race relations I mean where
else do you see a grown black man crying
over his white co-worker
it's my quarterback
on the field or court it's just about
who can get me the ball who can score
for our team when we need it they earn
each other's respect and the love
follows
so why does America have that in sports
something that is after all just a
diversion but not for stuff that really
matters
42 percent of private colleges admit
applicants based almost entirely on the
fact that their parents are alumni you
get in if you work hard and your dad
bought a building
these are called legacy admissions
although I will also accept entitled
but it also must be said that in the
interest of writing historical wrongs
and evening out our despicable past the
concept of Merit itself is now under
attack everywhere but in sports instead
of getting the kids who lag behind up to
the higher standards schools all over
are eliminating honors classes eighty
percent of four-year colleges no longer
require any standardized tests for
admissions San Francisco's top-rated
Lowell High School replaced merit-based
admissions with a lottery in 2021 and
the result was a three-fold increase in
D's and F's turns out getting rid of
Merit admissions just made kids feel
worse about themselves and that's what
Instagram is for
at least 16 schools in Virginia are now
under investigation for failing to give
students their National Merit
Scholarship Awards which are a big a big
deal they can open a lot of doors
academically and get you late at math
camp
foreign
Governor there called it a maniacal
focus on equal outcomes for all students
at all costs you may not like him but
that accusation strikes a lot of people
as true and this is a bad issue for
Democrats because most Americans seem to
agree if they're on an airplane they
want a cockpit that looks like America
but they'd also like someone up there
who knows how to fly the plane